when I was working on my undergraduate
degree at the University of Minnesota my
macro economics professor was Walter W
Heller professor Heller was sort of
famous he'd been president john f
kennedy's chairman of the Council of
Economic Advisers and after Kennedy's
assassination he continued in the same
post for President Lyndon Baines Johnson
until he had a disagreement with
President Johnson over raising taxes to
finance the Vietnam War this was at a
time when it looked like inflation would
begin to overheat the economy had
Johnson listened professor Heller the
inflation of 1970s might have been
avoided
you see Heller was a Keynesian economist
and very attuned to the role that the
government could play in keeping the
economy growing and on an even keel
professor Heller was nearing the end of
his career when I met him he retired
just a few years after I graduated his
course was rigorous and he was a
demanding teacher there's also a very
nice man at least he was nice to a young
undergraduate like me who asked
questions that would I look back on them
were not very sophisticated professor
Heller possessed a great command of the
economic theories of john maynard keynes
which in the heady days of the 1960s
were all the rage leaders and policy
makers like Heller and JFK had little
doubt the government intervention and
Keynesian economics could correct the
economic problems the country faced
arguments between the Keynesian and the
anti Keynesian have persisted ever since
and shaped much of the macroeconomic
debate even today but it was in an
article that Professor Heller wrote when
I was a student that had the greatest
influence on me becoming an economic
historian in 1980
Hellen published a short essay entitled
can there be another crash in it he
looked back at the Great Depression in
reviewing the causes of the depression
and comparing it with the economic
situation
in the late 1970s he concluded that it
was unlikely that a crash would ever
happen again so he was mostly wrong and
as a historian I now cringe when
scholars attempt to predict the future
based on an appeal to historical events
but at the time I was struck by the fact
the professor Heller was taking a
historical perspective on the study of
economics that he was interested in
looking to the past to explain how we've
gotten to where we are today and that is
something that historians are very much
interested in exploring so I gravitated
to history in my studies and
particularly to economic history after
graduating I went to work in business
for several years I worked for a
printing company this was at a time when
desktop publishing was taking off in the
printing industry especially quick
printing was booming but the age of
electronic media was waiting just around
the corner
I was afraid that the printing business
night might not be the best career
choice for me so I returned to school
this time for my doctorate since I had
always been interested in economic
history and people like Walter Heller
had shown me what a fascinating topic it
could be I chose that as my field
actually my greatest interest was in the
early modern period roughly from 1500 to
1800
I studied foreign merchant communities
and world trade before industrialization
toward the end of that period of history
an individual who would have a profound
effect on how we think about the economy
today and about economic history wrote a
very long and very influential treatise
that presented the way he thought the
economy worked the treatise was
published in 1776 a watershed year it
was the year of the American
independence and it was the year that
the Scottish enlightenment thinker Adam
Smith came to the public's attention as
the author of the seminal work an
inquiry into the nature and causes of
the wealth of nations Smith's book
outlined what he thought were the
principles of economic behavior he
described an invisible
and that guided human behavior for the
common good
underlying his book however is the
recurring theme of self-interest Smith
wrote it is not from the benevolence of
the butcher the brewer or the Baker that
we expect our dinner but from their
regard to their own interest Smith was
not the only early thinker to write
about how the economy works but he's
certainly the best-known most people
today including most economists think
that Smith was identifying some of the
universal truths or overarching laws
about human economic behavior one of
Smith's universal laws was that man is
basically a calculating self-interest to
being he implied that as individuals we
hold little regard for the community and
therefore that markets are mankind's
best hope for channeling behaviors for
the good of all society this belief
largely stemmed from assumptions that
Smith and modern economists make about
the way people behave indeed many
scholars suggest that free markets and
other modern economic concepts already
operated in the very distant past
historians on the other hand questioned
the value of posing universal laws of
human behavior and questioned even their
existence for the economic historian
explanation is the overriding concern
rather than tying ourselves to abstract
laws or confining human nature to
straitjackets of self-interest
historians prefer to dig into the
sources we want to see how things work
in practice in order to come to a better
understanding of why people act the way
they do in a general sense
economic history concerns itself with
the ways that mankind has structured his
environment in the past in order to
provide food shelter and clothing in
other words we're interested in
examining the process through which
society provides for its material
well-being now let's face it this
doesn't sound too terribly stimulating
compared to some other historical topics
politics and power glory and warfare
faith and ideology at the same time the
basic economic worries of finding food
providing for one's welfare are so much
part of human existence that economic
history is the study of power glory and
ideology I'm reminded of the slogan it's
the economy stupid coined by President
Clinton's presidential campaign adviser
James Carville in the 1990s when he
tried to keep staffers on message it
would not be off mark to state quite
boldly that the study of economic
history is the study of human survival
the implication is that we will need to
take account of all human
characteristics and how these
characteristics shape our behaviors in
economic history we concern ourselves
with the interplay between economic and
social political and cultural behaviors
this makes studying economic history a
pretty broad undertaking now on the
other hand economic history is not the
examination of the history of economics
as an academic discipline and we will
only lightly touch on the history of
economic thought we will focus on what
happened in the past rather than what
people thought about what happened in
the past even so we can't ignore
economic theories but they'll play a
very small role in our discussion of
economic history so what are the central
concepts of economic history well as
with anything else that depends on whom
you ask the late Nobel Prize winning
economic historian Douglas north
suggested that what is a particular
concern to the economic historian is
explaining the structure of the
institutional structures that underlie
and account for the performance of an
economic system and how these
institutions change over time for
economic historian Rondo Cameron the
most pressing concern was to explain the
origins of unequal levels of development
in the world while we will touch on many
of the concerns that Douglass North and
Rondo Cameron raised I think the charge
that David Landis gave two economic
historians is the most useful for this
course Landis was a professor of history
at Harvard who wanted economic
historians to trace and understand the
main streams of economic advances and
modernization that is how mankind came
to where and what we are in the sense of
making getting and spending so we will
need to ask some important questions if
we're to understand these main streams
of economic history and these are
questions that we can ask about the
present as well as about the past
for example first what was produced even
the most primitive societies had to
grapple with this question primitive
societies might think of it in terms of
what they could hunt what they would
plant when I was growing up that was a
question that my family asked each
spring when it came time to plant our
vegetable garden and it's a question I
asked my family even today when we plant
our garden and I will tell you that I
keep planting turnips that nobody wants
to eat simply because my dad always
planted them but this is also a question
that entrepreneurs have been asking for
thousands of years and startup tech
firms still seek to answer this very
fundamental question what will we
produce to how is it produced this
question forces us to look at resources
like labor and machines in order to
understand how goods were made in the
past looking at the changes that were
made to how things were produced helps
us to understand how we got to where we
are today and it's a question that
businesses also still ask how will we
produce it and free how did what was
produced get distributed this question
can be asked of the family of the
community and at the regional national
and international levels
thinking again about my dad's garden the
question was always how to get rid of or
distribute the overabundance of zucchini
squash we invariably were left with each
summer on a larger scale
asking this question helps us to
understand commerce the allocation of
resources and social welfare practices
now if some of these seemed to be pretty
simple questions and many economic
historians who posed them over the years
but they're anything but easy to answer
they encompass a lot more than they
might appear to these three questions
lead to discussions of prices resource
allocation production methods
technological development labor supply
and demand and the list goes on the
questions also point to issues that
economists and economic historians alike
address while doing so in very different
ways economists for instance practice
something that few historians are
comfortable with doing they look to the
future and try to predict what will
happen and could influence
decision-making this is the kind of
economist Walter Heller was until toward
the end of his career when he began to
see the benefit of taking a historical
perspective historians and this includes
economic historians are oriented toward
the past so we don't try to predict the
future nor do we try to offer advice on
how to fix the economy our attempts at
influence when they occur tend to be
more cautious historians and economists
also approach questions from different
methodological perspectives economists
tend to try to isolate the so called
independent variable in order to
identify regularities that might predict
human behavior but to us historians
again including most economic historians
this notion of isolating variables is
not in Tayna belen stead we suggest that
in attempting to explain what happened
in the past we need to consider as many
variables as possible actually most
historians consider all variables to be
interdependent removing any one of them
alters the situation so the explanation
suffers with that brief explanation
about what economic history is where do
we go from here well
I aim to describe and we'll try to
explain the long course of economic
history since about the year 1400 even
so I will have to set the stage leading
up to 1400 to help us get our bearings
my goal is to show how we got to where
we are today that's a pretty tall order
so if we would list some of the
highlights of the economic history of
the past 500 or more years
what would we include think about that
for a minute the world has changed a lot
in 500 years well if we were to make our
list in chronological order we would
probably include the development of
productive agriculture mankind moved
from hunter-gatherer to cultivator
millennia ago but only recently has
agriculture been productive enough to
allow people to focus our efforts on
other activities agricultural surpluses
created important changes for how
mankind provides for itself
second the development of business
contracts and agreements now business
contracts have existed for thousands of
years but the form these took changed
over time and hundreds of years ago gave
rise to a variety of partnerships in
corporate relationships third the
expansion of trade although the great
European voyages of discovery come
immediately to mind trade has expanded
in a multitude of ways over the
centuries local and regional trade has
always been far more important to the
economy and commerce in the rather
mundane goods like food and tools and
clothing expanded just as much as global
trade did forth the development of the
idea of economic nationalism or what
Adam Smith would have called the
mercantile system we usually call this
mercantilism today although it isn't a
perfect stand-in from my preferred term
economic nationalism fifth the
development of Science and Technology
and the routinization of knowledge how
does the development of science
technology relate to the economy well it
might be obvious today but new ideas
have long since radically affected how
we produce things and that address is
one of the central questions of economic
history 6 the shifts to industrial
production is probably the greatest
force in modern economic history the
transition that we refer to as the
Industrial Revolution was not really as
sudden occurrence as the term revolution
implies but it completely changed how we
produce what we produce and it changed
how we distribute what we produce in
significant ways 7th population growth
global population growth brought with it
a demographic revolution and changes in
our methods of production and resulting
increases in agriculture productivity
8 free trade and mass consumption these
concepts became increasingly important
in the newly industrial world as
factories spewed out ever larger
quantities of products industrialists
strove to tear down barriers to trade
and work to get consumers to accept
their mass-produced goods ninth
imperialism colonization and warfare the
forces of imperialism colonization and
warfare touched most of the world's
population and set up an enduring divide
between the global haves and have-nots
the result was social tension and
outright violence as the so called rich
societies sought to exploit the poor and
finally economic growth and development
the struggle between the haves and the
have-nots led in more recent years to
attempts to spread some of the wealth
around the world programs intended to
affect economic development and to help
stimulate economies to grow in form much
of our recent economic history so we
have quite a list and even that's just a
beginning
I intend to address each of these topics
and much
or in this course one recurring theme
that will thread its way through every
one of these topics is the concept of
capitalism now what does that mean how
do we define capitalism well some
scholars point out that the term
capitalism really refers to a social
construct rather than an economic system
and capitalist can be a difficult
concept to define is one of those terms
that people often say they understand
yet have a hard time explaining frankly
there are many possible definitions of
capitalism and many of them are
construed negatively defining capitalism
is even harder when we try to apply the
term to the past to a very different set
of circumstances in social and economic
contexts from our own world the word
itself is rather new capital basically
meaning assets dates as far back as the
Middle Ages but the word capitalism
originated only in the middle of the
19th century in the context of referring
to an economic system and then it was
usually used by socialists today most
people think of capitalism rather
idealistic aliy as a natural and
timeless human condition so let me try
to define the term and since I'm going
to be the one drawing up the list I will
say that some characteristics of
capitalism that we should include are
clearly defined property rights and
forcible contracts markets let's set
prices and institutions favourable to
the above elements this gives us a
starting point so capitalism could be
defined as an economic system in which
rational private property rights and
enforceable contracts provide for the
efficient functioning of markets that
generate price signals and for which
favorable institutions exist to create
incentives for participation in the
in this general statement private
property rights refers to the ownership
control and exchange of a resource or a
good and enforceable contracts are to
minimize costs and disputes now I
suppose this is quite a mouthful and
many scholars will nitpick parts of it
but that's capitalism in a nutshell the
problem is that this conceptualization
represents more of an ideal as a way of
thinking about the economy than it is a
description of reality at any point in
the past it also does not describe
economic relations during most of human
history in most parts of the world
aspects of it can be found in most
historical periods but rarely does the
capitalist system seemed to have been
functioning fully the way I just
described it for example in the Middle
Ages real property which under my
definition we would consider as a
resource could not be bought or sold the
way it is today if you could go back in
time and ask a medieval peasant who
owned the farm that he worked on you
might get a blank stare that's because
the idea of ownership was very different
than it is today so we will try to avoid
grappling with capitalism as an abstract
concept except in passing in the
lectures that follow and instead focus
on the markers of its development along
the way another concept we will pay
close attention to is the role of
institutions in economic history this is
an even more difficult concept to
describe than capitalism at its core the
study of institutions which I'll call
the rules of the game for a moment to
distinguish the term from the way it's
used in the sense of an organization or
an edifice the study of institutions is
the examination of the interaction
between and among individuals firms
States social and legal norms cultural
practices and so on you will recognize
that institution
change over time the rules that govern
much of human behavior things like
social and legal norms for example tend
not to be fixed and constant rather they
can change dramatically in turn such
changes can produce great confusion
among historical actors when they're
thrust into situations that put them
into contact with new and unfamiliar
institutional arrangements for example
when parties from very different
cultures come together to engage in
trade certain misunderstandings and
miscues are likely to occur until each
party adjusts to the new institutional
arrangements it is also true that when
we look to the past we attempt to
interpret actions and attitudes of
history into a contemporary
institutional framework we need to be
careful not to assume that historical
actors were operating under the same
preconceived notions that we are we need
to develop a historical consciousness in
order to make sense of the past now
scholars approach economic history from
a number of different ideological as
well as methodological perspectives let
me present three ideological
perspectives to offer a sense of the
differences you will encounter in the
subject and occasionally in my
presentations first is the neoclassical
economics in general neoclassical
economic historians apply economic
theory to historical processes in the
interests of understanding the past this
approach follows in the tradition of
Adam Smith and holds in high regard the
study of price theory utility and profit
maximization and the presence of
rational economic actors one drawback of
neoclassical economics as it applies to
the distant past is that it often
struggles with the so called free rider
problem which refers to those who
benefit from something without paying
for it and it has difficulty accounting
for cultural factors such as religious
beliefs among other things in human
action
second Marxian economic history Marxist
thought has had a big impact on economic
history and continues to do so to some
degree even today the basic focus of
Marxian economic thought is the mode of
production the Marxist historian views
every historical period as having its
own identity shaped by the ways in which
the means of production are owned and by
how people relate to one another in the
process of production and by the
material forces of production in this
view all of the modes of production
meaning the institutions that govern
production have built-in contradictions
that must be resolved through some kind
of struggle so to the Marxist the
driving force of human history is the
struggle of one class with another third
world Systems Theory well not a theory
of economics per se world systems
analysis has had an important role to
play in economic history rather than
viewing the nation-state as the most
important focus of historical analysis
world systems theory seeks to substitute
a regional or interregional approach
world Systems Theory also rejects the
notion that Marxists and most
neo-classicists alike commonly hold
which is that there is only a single
path to economic development for most
countries and regions now in this course
I have purposefully chosen to approach
certain topics from perspectives such as
these when it seems warranted but in
general my approach is as much
descriptive as it is explanatory so
again where do we begin this is a more
difficult question than it might seem we
could start in the very distant past and
examine the shift of men and women from
hunting and gathering to their first
attempts at cultivation or we might
begin when people first started using
coins to represent value or we might
begin with the first long-distance
commercial trade in the times of the
ancient classical empires but to
understand the
world we live in today I think we must
begin by focusing on Europe now I admit
that economic history has suffered from
a significant amount of Eurocentrism
that refers to a point of view that is
distinctly a European perspective and
you will notice a fair amount of
Eurocentrism in some of the stories in
history that follow but this will not be
to the exclusion of our voyages to other
corners of the globe and our focus to
the extent that it falls in Europe
reflects the fact that the world economy
has for so long been so dominated by
Western meaning European ideas and
ideals so it can be difficult to get
past this rather parochial viewpoint but
we will in the distant past Europe's
economy was rather insignificant
compared to the economies of the great
empires of Asia like India and China
still in our modern world the economic
system in institutions that developed in
Europe over the past 500 years or so are
the ones that have taken hold so if
we're going to try to find out how the
world economy got to the point where it
is today I think it makes sense to focus
on Europe I think it makes the most
sense to begin in medieval Europe
sometime after the breakdown of the
Roman Empire I choose the end of the
medieval period to begin discussing
world economic history because life was
not only very different from what even
Adam Smith experienced but people acted
and thought in ways that were very
different from what Smith described in
his own time not to mention what we
experienced in the world today the
French economic historian fredom brow
Dell summed up this shift in thinking
over the centuries when writing about
vagrancy he wrote in the 16th century
the beggar or vagrant would be fed and
cared for before he was sent away in the
17th century he had his head shaved
later on he was whipped and the end of
the century saw the last word and
repression he was turned into a convict
this was
Europe so it is in medieval Europe that
we begin to see not only significant
changes in the way people thought but
also the first baby steps toward what we
might consider a more modern economy
where will we end well we will progress
through several centuries of history and
end well at the end with a discussion of
today's increasingly globalized world my
hope is that at the end you will have a
good understanding of the major currency
of economic history